[Music]
Senator Marco Rubio gave the Republican
response to President Obama's State of
the Union speech yeah now a lot of
people are talking about it you can have
your your your opinions one way or the
other but there was one moment that made
me wonder whether Rubio was the right
choice to speak for the Republicans in a
short time that I've been here in
Washington nothing has frustrated me
more than false choices like the one the
president laid out tonight the force
isn't just between big government a big
business
[Applause]
[Music]
you could have waited you know they're
they're trying to reach out to young
people